i even think that what was the one clip
you did on uh comedy central i saw that
was i was like yeah yeah he's talking
about his life i was there
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah i did that like
white friends and uh-huh
yeah growing up in mesa and [ __ ] but
yeah it was like uh
i forget when i i think because i listen
to joe rogan
probably if not every episode when he
has some of the crazy kooky right wing
dudes i i fall off but yeah
but for the most part i probably listen
to like almost i would say 80
of all his [ __ ] and um
and i remember he brought you up and i
was like oh [ __ ] it's about to get real
for this kid
dude he's like the king maker yeah and
it was so wild is that
like literally i haven't even been on
his podcast yet
but literally anytime he says my name or
anything like that
i just start like all of a sudden i
start getting a bunch of follows and i'm
like
[ __ ] like what but it's like a lot at
like a time in a wild way and i'm like
the hell and then all of a sudden my
home like some of my homies would be
like yo
i heard it yeah broke is talking about
you right now he said this this and that
so how did you guys become friends bro
that was a random
that like all all the [ __ ] that happens
to me is so [ __ ] right because
for people who don't realize i mean joe
rogan is the most successful podcaster
ever and
for people who are watching this aren't
tapped in with the stand-up world like
he's like loki the king banger
like like like if you like if he like
co-signs you as a comedian
oh that's that's a big it's a big plug
it's a huge plug
yeah it's like i said they they compare
it to like johnny carson like back in
the day yeah like if you got on johnny
carson
yeah and now if you go do joe rogan's
podcast it's like you know
yeah you can at least go on tour oh yeah
yeah you gonna do good
yeah so you guys became friends how
um so the comedy store has this so they
have like they're paid regulars right
yep and they have this program where
like
you work your way up into a paid regular
call the development spots
and that's that's what that's like the
status i'm at
there right now and um uh
i was going to do like one of my
development spots so like they they put
a development spot like right at the top
of the show they just go up and do like
five minutes set blah blah blah spot for
the uh
for the week right and um i was doing
one
uh where rogan was on the lineup and um
we were uh i i'm usually like when i
first when i was
first doing them i would just kind of
just sit there quiet you know just
because all the big dogs are back there
and i kind of was just like
chilling in the corner you know what i
mean and uh
then he came on he just started talking
to me he's like what's up man i was like
oh what's up homie
like we just started uh chopping it up
then we started talking about
like we got real deep we all of a sudden
we started talking about like
you know he started talking about his
dad i started talking about like my you
know
stepfather and the crazy the crazy [ __ ]
we went through with them we started
talking about like
you know our anger problems we got like
then we started talking about books
and all this [ __ ] and it was it was a
really great conversation
and then um uh as i'm leaving because i
just
got off stage you know i went to go say
bye to him i was like all right joe you
know pleasure blah blah blah
and he was like wait what's your
instagram man i want to follow you blah
blah blah
i was like oh [ __ ] i was like you know
you know there it is i was already
following him right
[Laughter]
but yeah he started following me and
then you know uh
um i remember we had talked talked about
he geeks out over my cheerleading
of course he thinks it's like the
craziest thing yeah he's just like
a guy your size you know flipping doing
that throwing people around yeah he goes
it's it's insane like and i
because i you know a guy my size isn't
supposed to
be able to do the flips that yes like
i'm able to do it's not it's yeah it's
like it shouldn't be a thing it's a lot
of weight to like
carry yeah needless to say and so he's
just like
you know geeked out over that and um you
know
then he gave me his number he's like yo
come come open for me tonight at the
store you know i got a spot for you blah
blah
i was like whoa i didn't know if he had
like seen me
perform yet or anything like that but he
kind of was just like yeah
you know i'll throw you up and ever
since then we've just been
cool